you know I think I've changed my mind I
think that investing is [__] stupid
we had a friend is raising a fund right
now you know I think I've changed my
mind I think that investing is [__]
stupid I would have bet a thousand
dollars you're gonna say stupid I would
have been wrong cuz he's so [__]
stupid but like why is investing stupid
I would love to hear why investing is
stupid tell me if I am being like just a
baby here and like but it's just like I
just find this like financial arbitrage
[__] to be so boring and like
meaningless okay
and I watch the TV show billions and I'm
like oh that's cool like they're doing
all those big things it looks exciting
and then I'm like well those guys are
losers like they're not actually adding
to I mean they're just they're wealthy
and they're accomplishing dreams so I
respect it but I also I'm like oh my god
that's so soulless and that's what I
think like a lot of like I've got
friends that create these websites that
like they're already wealthy and they're
building these websites that are like
they're just Hawking [__] and they will
admit that they are I'm like the [__]
the point of this and that's kind of
what a lot of investing is but the
friends Hawking [__] that's different
than investing right that's just like
selling some degree for money right
it's fun it's definitely from a similar
yeah it's just like why like I like if
you're already can if you already have a
little bit of cash which if you're still
trying to get your hair you know go go
you got to go for it but if you already
got a little bit of cash like do
something cool and meaning so ok so
here's here's I'll give you two to
thoughts on this okay the first is an
example that supports your case and then
I'll give you the feel-good reason why
you're wrong so the support your case so
I mentor this guy who's 20 years old and
he's at this point where like he tried
to do some stuff I kind of didn't work
out and now he's like [__] do I
need to go get a job I need to pay my
bills I don't want to go move back home
with my parents and so he's like he's
like about to take this job and he's
like should I you know leave this
entrepreneurial path and go get a job
because I you know I need to pay bills
in two months and I don't think I can
spin something up in the next 60 days
that will get so profitable that I'll be
I know I'll be able to pay my rent and I
said you know I empathize with the
problem but I said you know let's just
slow down for saying before you go take
that consulting job let's just let's
just talk things through for a second so
I said how much money do you need to
live every month what's your burn rate
two grand two grand fantastic and I was
like so let's say you wanted a year of
runway to go try some [__] you need to
come up with 12 months times 2 grand
maybe to come up with 24 grand I said I
know you do some investing in the stock
market you're kind of a degenerate you
know you like to pick stocks the
attractive like Bitcoin and [__] I was
like because at the beginning of the
conversation he's like you know am I
good the thing that's going well is my
investments have done well the things
going bad is about to have to take this
job for my my bills like well those two
things don't add up I was like I was
like do you have enough money in the
stock market right now that you could
just sell and you could use to live off
of to chase your entrepreneurial dreams
he's like yeah I could but then I'd have
to sell and I don't want to sell cuz I'm
getting you know good returns I said
okay let's do the math real quick what
do you think you could generate per
let's take just a twenty four thousand
that you mean I don't know how much what
do you have you don't have to tell me
let's take the twenty four thousand that
you need how much do you think you could
generate per year in return average he's
like fifty percent I was like ok Minnie
Warren Buffett you think you could do 50
percent a year but let's let's assume
you're delusional
number is correct and that you could do
it consistently which is the hard part
you could do it for one year for sure
but consistently generate 50 percent so
let's say you you do the Warren Buffett
you you invest perfectly you get your
50% way above market return and you're
24 grand has turned into 36 grand now
like fantastic congratulations you made
$12,000 like you are still nowhere near
where you're trying to get with your
goals and if you and how many years
would you have to continue to get this
absurd return for you to be where your
goals are I was like not that many but
that would never happen you would never
happen right you never get to 50% so
anyways I was like you're you're talking
about this year going and trading
all your time for money at a consulting
gig when instead you could just sell
some of your stock get 24 grand of
runway and you could live for 12 months
and give yourself a bunch of shots on
goal to try to build something that you
believe in and you'll learn way more
you'll have way more fun and you'll have
way more upside than if you go take the
consulting job so like you're crazy so
he was of the mindset of well I heard
that rich people invest so I want to
invest and I want to get return I want
my money to work for money he had kind
of heard all these things and was in was
investing for that reason so I think
investing doesn't make sense when you
have very little amount of capital
overall and you're trying to go invest
that capital and then you're trading
your time for four dollars in other ways
now
the other so that's the argument for
times when I think investing would be
stupid is when you know if you take a
normal return the amount of money that
you're making every month is not every
year is not gonna change your life and
you're locking up money in the stable
what's the second point cuz I think the
second points gonna be better than the
first point the first point that you
made was that well only of us if you got
a lot yeah exactly if you if you don't
have a lot I'd rather you use that money
if you're entrepreneurial if you're one
of the five 5% of people who actually
want to build a business or do something
on their own you're better served
investing in yourself and investing and
buying your time back yeah and and and
going taking a bunch of shots uncle now
the second is is investing stupid well I
think you're kind of right that it is
not the most exciting thing but
excitement is different for everybody
but here's the cool way of thinking
about investing like for anything to
work you need leverage right so you were
on the hustle but day to day you write
zero emails probably you don't write the
daily email you don't do the trends
report this podcast is the most active
thing you do for the Hustle is that
correct it we could say yes for a sake
of argument okay so first sake of
argument your your argument is correct
I'm leverage so your leverage because
you got a bunch of humans doing work for
you cool
another form of leverage is media so
people are gonna let we're gonna stalk
for one hour and then this is gonna get
listened to for hundreds of thousands of
hours out there so media is another form
of leverage
and then the last one is capital
capitals another form of leverage and so
here's the cool way of thinking about it
which is if you have capital investing
is your way of allocating capital to
things that are either a gonna return
the most or be gonna like change the
world in a way that you care about and
so capital is your way of influencing
the way that the world goes because you
get to assign units of energy to
different companies and causes that are
that are gonna go do do do I get that I
think that's a great point I think that
with the what I'm completely burnt out
of it's just lame-ass investments
what's a lame-ass investment like you
don't have to use a name if you want to
kind of code name something like I've
got a friend that gave a lot of money to
some like an investor who's gonna buy a
bunch of multifamily real estate and
it's simply a like I've don't ever see
this I don't touch it like that this is
a 7% yes simply an asset class and it's
just a thing on a spreadsheet and I'm
like oh my god that's so boring like
that like I just I can't decide if I'm
being a little like [__] hater or yeah
but my or like when I have we have some
friends who are buying companies and
they just look for anything that like
checks the boxes of does net churn this
and is the acquisition cost this and
that's it that's all I mean like
mechanical yeah yeah and I get it and
I'm like all right that's a great way to
make money but it's just like so [__]
lame sometimes I'm like oh my god you
guys like can you like can we please do
something exciting so okay so here's the
here's the rub okay let's say you don't
invest you're gonna either a park cash
and on the side and do nothing with it
probably lamer than investing in it and
having the cash grow or be you're gonna
what's the what's door number see so
what else would you what do what would
you prefer to do with your capital
besides invest or leave it in cash
either start companies and even if that
means I don't run them or that's
investing yeah I'm not saying investing
using I'm using investing because I
can't think of a better word no
investing is cool
I mean investing is great but I'm just
saying like arbitrage is again starting
a company is arbitrage but I think you
understand what I'm saying yeah I get
where you're coming from I don't know I
I just I just hit me last week where I'm
like oh my god this is I don't want to
talk about a carry fee ever again or I
go like this is just so [__] lame
when like you see like like I think it
happened when I was traveling I'm like I
just see these normal ask people at the
gas station and they're with their wives
and kids and like they'd like I would
I'm Way more fascinated by just make
that person just a little bit happier or
a little bit better not like how do I
eat gout a little more profit out of
this service do you thing I'm like it's
like I saw these I remember be at this
gas station and I saw this mom give her
kid like a like generic coke and I was
like like help this mother like Oh
either afford or learn that this thing
or that thing is now is like how can we
help her make a better decision may be a
better decision easy not how do I get
five per second I think I actually
understand what you're saying now which
is it's not that investing is stupid
it's not that putting money in some
place and getting a return is stupid
what you are starting to get annoyed
over or tired of is the amount of the
amount of your mental energy that goes
towards thinking about how to
reproductive devote mental energy and
not we're just money go it's kind of
like I get that money you gotta do
something with the money might as well
put in a place that's gonna grow might
as well fund a company that's gonna do
something but it's about mentally
spending cycles thinking about how do I
get 7% verse 8% versa tax-efficient 9%
versus just mentally spending those same
cycles thinking about something else if
I kept reading a book talking to a
person building something cool writing a
song whatever it's gonna be is that is
that more accurate yeah just like get
out of this financial arbitrage
circle-jerk and actually make a
difference and have an exciting
wonderful life you
I vote myself and others I'm with you on
that I'm with you on that I catch myself
doing that all the time where I'm like
how many hours is my brain spending on
you know in this financial game and
there's some so amount that's correct
but it's very easy to slip into more
than more than what you need more than
what's adding value I love that TV show
billions and I'm like oh man like Bobby
ox raw rod this powerful billionaire guy
he's going to war versus other people
that's [__] awesome I love that yeah
he's an alpha and I'm like but he's also
just a jerk-off who's just trying to
like squeeze pennies out of this thing
at that thing and it's complete nonsense
right you know I mean yeah I think you
know I think what also happens is
important which is in your 20s you're
trying to figure out what you like
twenties in many ways about feeding ego
it's like whether you're partying trying
to make friends trying to date people
trying to you know get your get your
name on the map in you know your career
or your industry I feel like a lot of
people including myself their twenties
are spent feeding the ego and then your
30s are spent figuring out that okay my
ego is either full or it will never be
full and I actually want to feed the
soul in some kind of way actually become
more conscious of how I spend my time
and my energy and and then there's this
constant push and pull of like maybe I
just want to make a bunch of money like
maybe I'm not ambitious enough well I
think you can over money focus and
there's like these debates that I have
my head I sounds like you do too
I think you could do both and I think
that I guess the point is I'm beginning
to realize I love the builders more than
the alligators like yeah yeah yeah
exhibit [__] a builders over
alligators all day okay yeah good that's
a good that's a good way to end the
podcast
you
[Music]